[Music]
jason's in reading pennsylvania hi jason
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how you guys doing better than
we deserve what's up
well i got got a little dilemma here and
i'm trying to get it figuring out um
yeah i live with my girlfriend her and i
at the house and her son
lives there too and then he decided to
ask if we were okay with if his girl his
girlfriend got kicked out of his house
at her her mom's house so she moved in
with us
and they you know i agreed on like two
or three months and i'm figuring that
was infinity um they bounced between the
two of them and make like well over two
hundred thousand dollars a year so i
really don't see why they just won't
just take that step you know and my
girlfriend
basically on their side and every time i
was trying to say something it's like
i get like the backlash and i'm like oh
so i just don't know what to do
they need to have that kick in the butt
to get moving but i don't know how to
get her on board with me and it's just
it's so frustrating so frustrating
um
who owns your house who owns the house
actually we're renting the house we are
renting out who's on the leash
um it's just her it's just my girlfriend
actually so it's her it's actually her
house
yeah it's basically her house
when we got
she's allowing you to live there
yeah basically i guess
legally speaking that's what's up yeah
and she asked me she did it i know but
she's allowed i didn't say you were
there against her will but she's
allowing it she's the she's the least
person on the leash she's in charge yeah
yeah okay yeah yeah and so um
how how long have you been there
uh two years now okay and uh how old is
her son
26.
and the girl and his girlfriend is 20
and he was there before you got there
yeah yeah he said he was going to be
leaving a year after he he graduated
from his schooling and got his job it's
been
over a year now and it's just there's no
exit plan at all i'm like well what do
we do here you know
okay
um
[Applause]
the only way the only way i know how to
answer questions on this show is to tell
you what i would do if i woke up in your
shoes but i wouldn't wake up in your
shoes so
because i wouldn't have made these
decisions
um
so i think i've just gotta backtrack and
go okay
i think what we've got to decide here i
don't think you're going to get between
this lady and her
son when you are the boyfriend that is
not on the lease
yeah yeah you're not exactly in a
position of power relationally or
legally
and so i think maybe you've got to
decide if this is a permanent
relationship or not
oh that was more than i mean that's
that's what that's what the plan was
okay then if we're going to get married
then it's a different set of rules
oh yeah that was already in the play
well no no i mean
you know i think that's part of the
discussion here it's like honey okay
we're going to set a date
and you know
now if we're going to set a date now
we've got to go into pre-marriage
counseling and part of pre-marriage
counseling is how we deal with
uh extended family which is grown kids
parents in-laws cousins that are crazy
whatever yeah and if you don't have a
plan as a couple to stay unified while
you deal with extended family in other
words she believes you deeply love her
son and want what's best for him and she
does too
and we're going to treat them as 26 year
old adults that make 200 000 a year then
then you can do that as a husband and
wife and you need to be unified on that
before you become husband and wife
and um then that's also going to change
the status of the lease as well because
now we're both going to be husband and
wife on the house that we rent as a
couple now he's just trespassing once
you make that change
but right now you may be trespassing
with her agreement but she's in charge
of this right now
yeah
you don't have much you don't have much
of a ground to argue from right now so
um you know i i think you're gonna have
to you know turn up the heat on
progressing this
relationship and causing it to become a
marriage
and as a part of that deal with this
situation because i don't think there's
a chance in the current scenario that
you're going to get between her and her
baby boy
well yeah i'm not trying to get between
he's like yeah you are i
wow i just keep getting different
stories i wouldn't be
if i were you i'd be trying to get
between her because he needs to get his
butt out of there and be a man
yeah
but you're not in a position to cause
this to happen because right now
you're just a trespasser
yeah i know what you're saying i
understand from that aspect yeah they
just like keep hearing different stories
you know when they're saving for housing
i don't think you i don't think you're
gonna change the narrative here because
you don't have any influence
she he has way more influence with her
right now than you do
yeah that's my yeah it doesn't seem that
way that's my problem yeah that's a
relationship problem
and some of that is based on the fact
that you moved into her house
and you are not married
and so it changes the dynamic of the
relationship it's just the reality of
the process it changes the legality of
it but it also changes the dynamic of
how the relationship functions because
relationships are about
um
or one not about but one of the things
relationships are about is power
and who has it and who's
uh going to hand it over and back and
forth so you know in a good healthy
marriage there's a give and take of
power
um you know we laugh and say you know my
wife wants to get her nails done i don't
understand but she goes against it done
but that's a giving up of power there's
a different you know and so i choose to
serve my wife but that's a handing of
power she chooses to make me dinner
that's a handing of power she you know
she's serving we all are giving you know
these are power transfers and you're in
a powerless
position
yeah that's good that's really good i
think especially approaching it from a
marriage perspective and just a
relational perspective i have a lot of
questions with the relationship with the
um the son and kind of the resistance to
that but i think you're right to first
kind of deal with it directly with the
girlfriend and kind of work on that
relationship first because that
narrative between her and him that's
seems to go pretty deep
yeah
i mean
there's
you know we're perpetuating
stupid ideas here is what it amounts to
um but you're not in a position to do
anything about it right now so you're
gonna either have to
get in a position of
power so that you can be gentle in kind
because you really can't be gentle and
kind when you're weak
it causes you to thrash about
and i remember one time when uh rachel
was a brand new baby
we looked up and her toddler sister was
carrying her down the stairs
and we about had a heart attack because
this is an accident looking for a place
to happen point being the weak can't
carry the weak
the strong should can carry the weak
that's you know you can't do it from a
position of weakness and so you can't be
kind and gentle from a position of
weakness you can't be
can't carry a newborn down the stairs
when you're virtually a newborn yourself
and so you know the you have to get
yourself
financially in a position relationally
in a position
and
legally in a position where you can be
kind and gentle to this young man then
you can put your arm around him and you
know whisper in his ear and kick his
little butt and get him out he makes 200
000 views he's 26 years old time to get
on with it boy
be a man step up
step out but you can't do that when
you're the move-in boyfriend it don't
work
it just you don't have the leverage
you're not in a position sorry
and uh it's good it's a good question
it's an interesting discussion but it's
uh it's one of the dynamics that we face
in our culture today
um because there's a one things we face
you and i face all the time we're trying
to answer questions for people that are
shacking up on how to handle money like
a married couple when they're not a
married couple because you really can't
you're really roommates legally
relationally spiritually you know you're
still fighting over who bought the
mustard
like you're like you had a roommate in
college you know that's my mustard
that's your master don't you you bought
that mustard did you why can i have some
of your mustard you know you're doing
all this crap you don't do that when
you're married you don't have my mustard
your mustard it's just our mustard when
you're married you know and
where's our mustard you know it's not
like where's my mustard you know it's
just
i'm standing looking at the door and
it's right there but i can't see it this
is a husband thing right but the uh
all of that to say it's very difficult
to do things in a way when you're not
that thing
right and uh that's that's what we
process here and there's all kinds of
data to back this up it's not just an uh
an old fart with a moral statement you
know there's stuff going on here